at this time tomorrow night we will be
in Iowa for a very special town hall
with Donald J Trump to get your tickets
go to hannity.com they're free tonight
we are right here in New York City with
the only people that are normal in New
York
we have a live audience show now my
monologue is coming up in just a bit we
begin tonight though this Fox News Alert
as we speak in the U.S House of
Representatives they are now poised to
vote on the McCarthy Biden budget
compromise bill but is it expected to
pass here at the very latest from
Capitol Hill all things Hitchhiker's
Guide to Washington DC and the swamp
Chad program is with us Chad what's
going on we expect this to pass don't we
yeah Sean good evening in fact we think
that they're going to start this vote
here in the next two to three minutes
they started this debate at 7 17 eastern
time and we think the actual roll call
vote is going to come any minute here so
it's pending we do expect a bipartisan
Coalition of Democrats and GOP members
to vote Yes House speaker Kevin McCarthy
made the closing argument he said don't
let the perfect be the enemy of the good
I could say
I'm going to vote no
because there's something not in the
bill
if I took that philosophy I would never
vote Yes
I simply read the bills in front of me
and decide is this good
for the country
I would say that answer is easily yes
taxpayers will save an additional 2.1
trillion and for the first time in more
than a decade Congress will spend less
next year than this year
once the bill clears the house tonight
it heads across the Rotunda to the
Senate it's a race to finish the bill
before the June 5th deadline that's when
the nation runs out of cash
how long weekend do you think is
reasonable
this has to get done over the weekend or
Friday I can tell you what I hope
happens is that those who have
amendments if given votes will yield
back time so that we
can finish this Thursday or Friday
and Sue the country and sues the markets
but GOP Senators Mike Lee and Rand Paul
want the Senate to consider other debt
ceiling plans first they likely score a
vote on their efforts in the closing
hours and Sean uh I'm just looking at
the house floor here I believe that they
are just about to start this roll call
vote in fact they just have already
there are 55 votes on the house floor
they just started this now again each
roll call vote in the house is allotted
for 15 minutes here you look at that
clock on the lower part of the screen
that counts down it will get down to
zero however again as I say it's like
soccer they keep the time on the field
and so they will allow people to
continue to come in watch for Democrats
a lot of them might hold their votes
back to see how many votes Republicans
post on the scoreboard first and after
you know the Republicans have put their
votes on then the Democrats will likely
vote for the bill and bring this across
the finish line again we're expecting a
wide bipartisan vote on this tonight
Sean all right Chad thank you as always
we appreciate it now as I outlined last
night this debt ceiling compromise has a
lot of critics and chief among them are
the conservatives in the Republican
house uh that is of the party of speaker
McCarthy they did make a fundamental
mistake in my opinion and that is the
speaker in my view should have kept all
members in the loop with the
negotiations before anything was agreed
to and the anger on the right at least
29 that I can that I have counted is
very palpable now conservatives do hate
the lack of real budget cuts the
original plan pays passed by the
Republicans did in fact cut 4.8 trillion
over 10 years this one is 2.1 trillion
and yes the it's the first time they'll
have a lower budget next year than the
year prior uh but as of now the federal
government's insane covert level
spending is pretty much here to stay
because only 30 billion of the
multi-trillion relief funds are going to
be clawed back and redistributed to
other areas of the government and the
cuts to Biden's Army of IRS agents well
that cut was minimal at best Democrats
meanwhile they hate the new energy
measures in the bill including that
pipeline that Joe manchin wanted and
rightly should have in West Virginia
they also hate that Americans with
student loan debt will be forced to
resume payments uh what I'm supposed to
pay for their education I paid my my
paid my loan back you can pay your own
loan back anyway even though Biden's
loan forgiveness program will still move
ahead neither side is particularly happy
with the new work requirements for
certain social welfare programs now this
seems like a win for conservatives and
some angles but does very little to curb
costs or get people back to work you
know it's kind of like rearranging the
decks the deck chairs on the Titanic
Titanic now my next guest Senator
Lindsey Graham he's vowing to undo this
debt deal he is is calling it quote a
disaster for National Defense according
to Graham the bill will Usher in the
lowest level of defense spending
relative to GDP in modern American
history this as the U.S has now been
thrust into a new cold war with
communist China as they have now created
a new axis of Evil and that's China
Russia and Iran and this week we watch
China refuse an American invitation to
meet with U.S defense officials they
also made aggressive manures against a
U.S fighter jet over international
waters and even built a simulation of
their Hypersonic missiles literally
destroying our entire U.S Fleet in the
Pacific and they still will not take any
responsibility for covid-19 nor is Joe
Biden holding them accountable for that
or for the Spy balloon that he let fly
all across the United States over every
military installation in the continental
U.S and Alaska they demanded that
America apologized for shooting down
their spy below soon after Biden let it
fly across the country for days and with
each passing week the threats to reunify
with our Ally Taiwan they're getting
more and more aggressive that seems a
question of when not if the goal of the
U.S should be peace through strength and
with the military so badass Kick-Ass so
powerful in advance that China would be
deterred from ever starting any conflict
around the globe unfortunately there's
nothing strong about Joe Biden he is
weak he is frail and we all know he's a
cognitive mess and he has no idea that
today is Wednesday and now as a result
the world is less safe for example look
at Putin's war in Ukraine there's no
ends in sight keep him in mind this war
started in part because of Biden's
weakness that he showed in Afghanistan
recently Russia issued an arrest warrant
for South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham after he praised America's
massive Financial contribution to
Ukraine Graham called it quote the best
money we've ever spent now fortunately
for Graham I doubt he had any plans to
vacation in Moscow like his Senate
colleague Bernie Sanders hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else